is there anything better than watching a
Disney movie we didn't think so many of
us grew up on Disney which is why we're
super excited to feast our eyes on the
latest live-action remakes although it's
hard to believe some of these remakes
are even better than the original films
let's take a look at the 10 best changes
in Disney's live-action history watch
until the end to find out why Disney's
The Lion King is set to surpass our
wildest expectations while some are born
to feast others spend their lives in the
dark 101 Dalmatians
you might think that Disney's
live-action remakes are a pretty new
thing but they actually started making
them back in the 90s and one of the
first was 101 Dalmatians the original
animated version was released way back
in 1961 it's a classic but it can be a
little dated Roger and his dog Pongo
live in London they meet Anita and her
dog
Perdita the humans fall in love with
each other and so do the dogs the dogs
have a litter of dalmatian puppies and
then a woman named Cruella De Vil wants
to take them she wants a fur coat made
of Dalmatian fur can you say creepy she
soon kidnaps the pops and puts her plans
into motion when the puppies get rescued
they come home with even more Dalmatians
than before in 1996 Disney released a
live-action version it was pretty great
the acting was amazing and the legendary
Glenn Close played Cruella De Vil she
was perfection
casting Glenn as Cruella was the best
thing Disney could have done they also
spent way more time on korilla story by
giving her more of a background if we
make this coat it would be as if I were
wearing your dog she was able to appear
even more wicked
[Laughter]
alice in wonderland'
in 2010 they decided to tackle another
classic Disney movie Disney hired Tim
Burton to direct Alice in Wonderland and
this film was awesome the original movie
came out way back in 1951 that is older
than some of your grandparents alice is
a bored little girl she follows a rabbit
wearing a pocket watch and falls into
Wonderland she experiences all sorts of
crazy things
there are potions that make her shrink
and others that make her grow she meets
the Mad Hatter and has a tea party with
talking animals and she becomes the
enemy of the Wicked Queen of Hearts the
whole movie is pretty random and very
peculiar Disney took it to a whole new
direction in 2010 Tim Burton is known
for directing some really dark films and
he turned Alice in Wonderland into a
really creepy movie but the sets and
costumes were gorgeous
Burton casts Johnny Depp and Helena
Bonham Carter of course but the best
change was in the truth about Wonderland
Alice had visited the magical land first
as a naive little girl but this world is
not a happy place it turns out it was
really called underworld so creepy
Maleficent Disney decided to keep up
this dark streak with their next
live-action remake and this time they
decided to tell a classic story from a
whole new point of view Sleeping Beauty
is a classic Disney princess movie it
was released in 1959 Princess Aurora is
being blessed by fairies at her
christening but Maleficent the mistress
of all evil shows up she is offended
that she wasn't invited to Aurora's
party so she decides to curse the
princess she casts a spell that will end
her life when she turned 16 and pricks
her finger one of the good fairies
changes the curse so that Aurora will
fall into a long sleep instead Aurora
gets saved by Prince Philip who defeats
Maleficent but it all seems so random
why does this lady want to cause Aurora
pain and suffering you don't go around
cursing people when they don't invite
you to things didn't you decided to fix
this plot hole in 2014 if they released
Maleficent and it is all about
Maleficent side of the story we learn
why she became evil she had been trying
to save her people the face
Cary's but the humans were cruel and
massacred them she curses Aurora in
revenge it's a great film starring
Angelina Jolie and we were so glad we
found out the truth about Maleficent
Cinderella the next movie that Disney
decided to modernize is Cinderella the
original movie was released in 1950 he
know the story Cinderella has a wicked
stepmother and stepsisters they won't
let her go to the ball her fairy
godmother dresses her up and the prince
falls madly in love with her after one
dance she loses her glass slipper and
the prince sends his men to scout the
city until they find her
when Cinderella's finally found the
prince marries her and they all live
happily ever after but no one falls in
love after one dance Cinderella has been
criticized for his unlikelihood and mal
focused splott Disney fix this in 2015
there are a lot of great changes in this
movie we get to see Ella's relationship
with her mother and father before they
pass away and she meets the prince
before the ball they don't know who the
other really is but they learn a lot
about each other in this time it's a
good foundation for a relationship the
other great change is the fairy
godmother Helena bonham-carter adds a
goofy spin to the classic character and
don't forget that the movie taught us to
be kind and have courage the jungle book
The Jungle Book came out in 1967 it was
the last movie to be directly approved
by Walt Disney himself this movie
followed Mowgli a boy who was raised in
the jungle by wolves but soon Mowgli is
targeted by sheer Khan a man-eating
tiger the Panther who saved Mowgli tries
to get him to live with humans for his
own safety but Mowgli doesn't want to
hear ends off and encounters all sorts
of dangers in the jungle he befriends
Baloo the bear who helps protect him
eventually he decides to move into the
village after seeing a pretty girl his
age in 2016 Disney made a live action
version of the jungle book and it was
epic the cinematography was amazing and
the CGI animals were so realistic the
plot was more or less the same for most
the movie but the best change was the
ending
Mowgli's entire life was in the jungle
the
the Panther and Baloo are his family in
the live-action movie he defeats Shere
Khan and he decides to stay with his
family in the jungle it got us right in
the fields we loved all the changes in
this version UT and the Beast Disney
remade a bunch of the classic era films
before diving into the Disney
Renaissance but in 2017 they decided to
remake some of the more modern animated
movies they started with Beauty and the
Beast the 1991 version was a classic
that was unhappy in her village Belle
and her dad are total outcasts she saves
her father by sacrificing herself to the
Beast to a nearby enchanted castle all
of the castles staff have been turned
into household objects the music is
amazing and Belle is a much more
powerful heroine than the princesses who
came before her but it always left us
with a lot of questions why is it winter
in the nearby castle why do none of the
villagers know that a prince lives a few
hours away the 2017 version answered all
of these questions The Enchantress who
cursed the prince made the villagers
forget all about the castle and she also
cast a spell that caused the kingdom to
be stuck in a state of perpetual winter
but one of the best changes in the
live-action remake was Belle's
personality she's a lot more of a
go-getter she still loves books but
she's also an inventor
she even invents a laundry machine at
the beginning of the film she also takes
her fate into her own hands and tries to
escape right away it's pretty clear that
after the first night she is no longer a
prisoner
we loved Belle's modern upgrade
Christopher Robin our next live-action
Disney movie isn't a remake of just one
film but it does give us a whole new
look into the world of Winnie the Pooh
Disney has made a lot of Winnie the Pooh
stories there have been several movies
and TV shows some were really popular
like the Tigger movie and they are all
little different but they all featured
the same lovable stuffed animals who
live in the 100 Acre Wood these
characters are based on a real boy named
Christopher Robin and his lively stuffed
animals in 2018 Disney released
Christopher Robin we get to see
Christopher Robin and his pals as kids
but the boys forced to grow up
to fast as an adult he is not really
happy with his life but then his
childhood stuffed bear shows up and he
can talk Christopher reunites with his
old toys he masters what it means to be
a kid again he learns what is really
important in life like his family
Christopher turns his life around with
the help of Pooh in the gang it's
adorable and it will hit kids and adults
right in the fields we just love that
Disney decided to show us a grown-up
Christopher Robin Dumbo the original
Dumbo is the fourth Disney animated
movie to ever be created it was released
in 1941 the movie is about a circus
elephants names Dumbo who has huge ears
and he can fly he gets separated from
his mom as a baby but with the help of a
mouse he becomes a star eventually he is
reunited with his mom but they get their
own act it's a total tearjerker but it's
a classic nonetheless Dumbo was remade
into a live-action film and released in
2019 this movie is still pretty new so
if you haven't seen it skip ahead
because spoilers are coming up quick
anyway the live-action film is very
different from the original but these
changes were all super necessary in the
last few decades circuses have been
criticized for animal cruelty and the
movie didn't shy away from the truth one
of the best changes was the addition of
two new characters Millie and Joe who
happened to be the children of Dumbo's
caretaker they go out of their way to
help Dumbo reunite with his mom but the
best change is the end Dumbo and his
mother are reunited and they get to live
with the other elephants in the wild we
love this ending so much Aladdin it
looks like 2019 is the year of
live-action Disney remakes and we aren't
complaining the original aladdin came
out in 1992 it's about an orphan boy who
finds a magic lamp he gets a genie who
helps him become a rich prince this
helps him win the hand of Princess
Jasmine
I choose you he defeats the evil Jafar
and lives happily ever after the new
movie looks pretty similar to the
original but the real sets and costumes
are amazing we're pretty bummed that
Robin Williams is no longer around to
play the genie
but for confident that Will Smith will
do a great job there's one major change
we are really excited about and it has
to do with Princess Jasmine she's not
just a girl who sits alone waiting to be
married off she is a political force who
stands up to her dad the Sultan and she
has a handmaiden who is also her best
friend they support each other no matter
what we're so happy to see that Princess
Jasmine has a human friend in the
live-action movie no offence Raja The
Lion King okay we're using the term
live-action a little loosely here but a
brand-new CGI version of The Lion King
is coming out in July of 2019 and we
cannot wait the original version of The
Lion King is one of the most successful
movies of all time the 1994 movie was
about Simba a young lion cub he is the
son of the King Mufasa
but Mufasa is betrayed by his evil
brother scar which results in him losing
his life young Simba is forced to run
away into the jungle he is raised by
Timon and Pumbaa his childhood friends
Nala finds him and brings him home he
defeats scar and becomes king it's an
epic movie with an amazing soundtrack
the movie looks like it will have pretty
much the same plot but we are so excited
about some of the new cast members Seth
Rogen is playing
Pumbaa he will be perfect for the goofy
warthog Donald Glover is voicing Simba
and Elton John and Tim Rice are writing
a brand new song for the movie we cannot
wait to see the new version of the Lion
King
what Disney movie do you want to see as
the next live-action remake tell us in
the comments thanks for watching if you
love all things Disney be sure to
subscribe to the things and don't forget
to give this video a big thumbs up we'll
catch you next time
[Music]